[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chat
années quand vient l'été on nous dit de
manger léger le fait bien sûr cassoulet
de faire des abdos fait
mais nous c'est bon
on appris
[Musique]
dans décision au fait
au sol
couscous à la playa supplément harrison
kenny est pas là y en aura plus de temps
le plein on mange avec les doigts
c'est bien meilleur hoya on pousse sur
un stade à dunkerque ou djerba
[Musique]
mais yamaha
petit koala
baba ça va
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
frérot sur la tête de ma robe je
comprends rien à ce que chante te
fatigue pas viens viens trop servir
seront
[Applaudissements]
avec les doigts c'est bien meilleur on
peut sur un staff a naguère coup à
djerba où ça la paille
supplément harris how can qui n'y est
pas
il y en aura plus c'est bien meilleur
sur sa à dakar ou à djerba
ça la playa supplément harissa et n'est
pas là il y en aura plus dans le mange à
écrire c'était vraiment ça rajoute du
chocolat
[Applaudissements]
l'étang des rallyes c'est là